[Música]
bom eu vim aqui hoje compartilhar um
pouco da minha história com vocês
mas antes de eu contar minha história eu
quero começar pela história da minha mãe
a minha mãe quando tinha 12 anos de
idade ainda criança e morava no piauí
ela teve a mãe assassinada e o pai
infelizmente não foi o suficiente para
criar todos os seus filhos
então ele deu os filhos ea minha mãe ela
foi adotada por uma pessoa que eu nem
sei por que ela adotou uma criança
porque a minha mãe me relatava que ela
era torturada todos os dias e um desses
relatos ela me contou que a mulher pegou
a cara dela e passou no chão e disse o
olympique chão
então minha mãe mesmo com apenas 12 anos
de idade fugiu do piauí para são luís e
eu imagino que a história de vida da
minha mãe deve ter sido de muito
sofrimento
até o dia em que ela conheceu meu pai
imagina que ela foi passando e meu pai
lá no canto e aí é ficha é lixa amor à
primeira vista
então os dois começaram a namorar e
foram morar juntos ea nossa infância foi
muito sofrida nós morávamos em uma casa
de barro explorada por madeiras por
todos os lados final a casa caía e
quando chovia
se fosse de madrugada todos tínhamos que
ficar acordado até a chuva passar porque
entrava água por cima e por baixo dentro
entanto nem tudo tanto sofrimento do que
mais me machucava era quando não
tínhamos comida
em se tratando de comida uma vez teve
uma sequência de três dias em temos o
que comer e eu estava com tanta fome
neste terceiro dia que eu fui dormir pra
esquecer a fome
só que eu achei de sonhar que tinha uma
bacia de caldo de galinha na bacia de
farinha hoya
só que quando eu fui dando o primeiro a
primeira dentada na galinha minha mãe
acordou
aí eu fiquei julia e injuriado o anão
mãe na hora da primeira dentada na
galinha só deixa de me acordar senhora
eu me lembro também que teve uma vez que
quando eu cheguei à minha mãe estava
chorando no beco aí eu me aproximei
perguntei mãe porque ela está chorando
ela falou meu filho porque eu nunca
imaginei que eu não iria ter condições
de alimentar os meus filhos de colocar
comida na mesa dos meus filhos me
aproximei dela passar a mão na cabeça
dele e falei mãe um dia nós vamos sair
dessa um dia nós vamos sair dessa
mas o pior momento que eu tinha um misto
de tristeza revolta e depressão era hora
de eu ir para a escola porque se não
bastava os poucos móveis que nós
tínhamos era todos doado por moradores
que não queria mais o farão um sofá
velho sol o paulo
mas o pior momento é quando eu tinha que
ir pra escola com tenha que foi dado por
alguém
um tênis maior que meu pé e muito velho
então o trajeto até a escola era muito
sofrimento para mim porque eu tinha no
meu pé porque na minha cabeça todos
sabiam que eu estava usando um tênis que
ninguém que queria mais e no trajeto até
a escola e ia pensando cara como é que
pode
como é que pode algumas pessoas terem
tudo e outras pessoas não têm nada
como é que pode algumas pessoas gastarem
até dois mil reais com a comenda do
cachorro e outras pessoas virarem lixo
pra comer
como é que pode e eu só me sentia bem
quando eu já estava na sala cercado de
cadeira e alunos aí eu dizia pronto
agora ninguém pode a mais no meu pé
isso foi me deixando muito revoltado eo
meu pai cometeu um erro muito grave ele
colocava o fardamento e pensava
eu estava indo para a escola já não ia
mais para a escola eu ia pra qualquer
lugar - a escola
então certo dia eu estava em casa meu
pai chegou muito triste
falou-se no senta ao meu filho por que
você fez isso comigo
estou vindo da escola fiquei sabendo que
você está há três meses sem na escola
meu filho
olha nós não temos nada olha o teu redor
se nós não temos nada a única coisa que
eu posso deixar pra você meu filho é a
educação hoje eu sei o quanto é
importante que ele falou pra mim mas
naquele momento não adiantava mais
perguntei pai você estudou falou estudei
meu filho o que adiantou se acabou de
falar não temos nada sai bate à porta e
eu acredito que deixei meu pai muito
magoado nesse dia o tempo foi passando e
eu entrei para a adolescência já era
considerado o líder de gangues de
pichadores e eu já tinha vários inimigos
eu já não podia ir em vários locais
porque eu sabia que se eu não me vigiar
se seria assassinado e eu pichava às
vezes frase de efeito colocava meu nome
mesmo ao fino às vezes eu colocava
frases de efeito
alcino mais embaixo
o egoísmo é uma doença a solidariedade
ea cura mas às vezes eu só tirava onda
alfino parei pra mijar e resolvi pixar
ia me achando cara com o passar do tempo
vários amigos meus foram sendo
assassinado
a coisa foi ficando mais séria além dos
amigos assassinado teve um amigo meu que
quando ele percebeu o inferno que nós
tínhamos entrado o buraco que nós
tínhamos entrado ele tirou a própria
vida ele se matou
já estava marcado para morrer uma certa
vez a minha mãe chegou em casa e falou
meu fiel fino
eu estava no supermercado e as pessoas
estavam comentando sem saber que eu era
sua mãe auxílio não vai demorar morrer
cana ele não faça esse carnaval vivo e
aí a minha mãe começou a chorar eu deixa
falar a mãe quer saber pra mim morrer
vai ser um alívio porque eu não aguento
mais essa vida mãe sair dessa vida quem
sabe a morte me liberta desse sofrimento
porque eu não aguento mais
e aí uma certa vez quatro cara formados
para me matar
foram muitos tiros nesse dia
um tiro pegou na perna de um irmão meu
alguns vivem foram baleados e um tiro
pegou na barriga da minha mãe ela veio
na minha direção falou meu filtro
baleada e levaram à minha mãe para o
hospital e eu fiquei em casa imaginando
caramba eu vou ser o responsável pela
morte da pessoa que mais me deu amor
estudo por mil você é o responsável pela
morte da minha mãe
e essa noite ela foi muito complicada
mas graças a deus a minha mãe voltou pra
casa com vida
no outro final de semana chega em uma
festa e um cara me chamou alcino vai lá
fora que deram um tiro no teu colega e
eu saí eu vi os comentários fiquei
sabendo quem foi
fui na minha casa e peguei um 22 que era
uma arma potente naquela época
peguei um 22 e coloquei aqui na perna da
minha calça e sair
estava chovendo muito e eu sair debaixo
de chuva
se eu achasse e ficará eu ele iria
morrer
então passei em frente a um clube de
pagode e lá estava o professor roberto
que é é professor de uma escolinha de
futebol e quando eu fui passando ele me
chamou alcino chega aí o rapaz depois
roberto ele chega aí caramba pra depois
ele chega e me convenceu
eu saí da chuva entrei no baile puxe uma
cadeira alcino
senta aí cara roberto 60 e passar o feno
já percebi que você lidera uma galera
jovem ficaria o rapaz eu não sou líder
de nada no líder e ninguém lhe der
alcino não tenho certeza se você tiver
pressa jovens vão e matam um
arrependimento eles vão me matam se você
de fé vão e quebra aquilo ali esses
jovens vão e quebram
você já imaginou se liderasse uma galera
pro bem ao filho seja imaginou se libera
essa galera povo pra lutar por melhorias
no seu bairro na sua rua por uma escola
de qualidade eles iriam te ouvir cara a
ele eu não sei em que momento que tutti
perdeu cara mais cara não é tarde cá eu
tenho certeza que você é um cara bom
e aquela conversa foi me transportado
por um lugar de paz
pensando eu sou bom eu posso ser útil
porque até então onde eu chego as
pessoas se afastam de mim e querem que
ninguém ande com alcino e por aí vai
e de repente mente dizendo que eu só
posso ser útil
então quando aquela conversa terminou a
única coisa que eu queria era voltar pra
casa e mesmo molhado ele me deu um
abraço quente falou-se no minha mão e eu
fui pra casa e aquilo aquela conversa
tirou uma venda dos meus olhos porque
quando eu cheguei em casa que eu vi a
minha mãe deitada naquele sozinho meu
pai é um perfeito como fugir oca
como eu fui burro
aí a vida que os meus pais tenham
poderia está ajudando
perdi todo o tempo da minha vida com
coisas que não me levaram a nada e o
cara essa noite foi a noite mais longa
da minha vida porque eu tive um encontro
com roberto e quando o dia amanheceu não
queria mais aquela vida pra mim e aí eu
não ia mais para canto nenhum eu ficava
em casa lendo todos os livros que
encontrava pela frente
jornais e aí um certo dia eu passando na
deodoro tava tendo uma roda de break e
um amigo meu já suelen me deu um disco
de rap do tarde e de um é de que até
apresenta um programa a liga aí eu
escutei o diz que disse é isso que eu
quero pra mim cara e aí eu comecei a
compor lê buscar informações com por ter
um evento lá no anjo da guarda e aí eu
pedi a oportunidade para cantar e o cara
deu a oportunidade a ele
bom galera agora vai subir aqui o alcino
alcino vai cantar um é o que mesmo
rep ele isso como rep fábio falou o nome
você mesmo aí e aí galera
mas eu vou cantar um rap significa ritmo
e poesia revolução através das palavras
e aí eu cantei a galera mais um mais um
eu só tinha aquela música ah mas eu
deixei só querendo sempre os colegas viu
aí a galera gostou apareceu até em casa
ela só eu falando que não papagaio
rapaz vi e aí eu comecei a correr atrás
desse sonho de compor e d também
oportunizar aos jovens para ouvir algo
positivo para acreditar que tudo era
possível que nunca era tarde
um certo dia quando eu cheguei em casa
estava na sala e aí teve um grito na
cozinha lá na cozinha não é
só assim a parede até a sala ea cozinha
mas que foi a paz assim que o pai tarde
sentindo se sentindo muito mal a minha
mãe falou elevar o meu pai no quintal aí
ele pediu pra minha mãe que se retirasse
que ele queria conversar comigo eu fui
pai e leal se notou muito doente meu
filtro muito doente e eu não sei se eu
volto eu falar isso não parece que vai
voltar sim sueli alcino todo muito
doente meu filho e eu não sei se eu
volto e é você que vai cuidar da família
se não cuidar da tua mãe cuida do teu
irmão já tinha um fip quem ele cuida do
teu fiz porque eu não volto mais no
filho e aí meu pai entrou na ambulância
e eu vi a porta se fechar e lindon e não
voltou mais
e aí eu fui pintava imaginei como eu vou
cuidar da minha mãe do meu filho sou
nada cara eu não sou ninguém com mas eu
aceitei o desafio e aí eu passei a
vender o irmão de madrugada eu eo joão
paulo ia pra feira 2 da guarda e aí às
vezes comprava depósito de sair andando
quilômetros e só voltava para casa após
ter vendido porto feliz de saber que eu
conseguia com dignidade
e aí eu continuei compondo ea e buscando
meus sonhos
ninguém acreditava mas eu eu acreditava
e aí eu comecei a compor gravar o meu
certeiro em primeiro cd de forma
independente e aí as empresas começaram
a me chamar pra mim prestar serviço para
elas através do rap falando sobre meio
ambiente sobre dst drogas
e aí é uma certa vez eu fui para marabá
para ministrar a aula
quero é ir à aula a criança aprendeu a
compor e assim estudar aquele tema ea
era meio ambiente eu estava escrevendo
lá aí um aluno de viajar só tarisse
rapaz eo eu começava a escrever explicar
e vocês são muito zé ruela perdendo
tempo com esse cara rapaz aí a gente
chama ter um rebarbado aí
aí o jovem se você não quiser assistir à
aula eu entendo e respeito você pode
instalar no pátio e aí ele foi sair o
bateu à porta e saiu lá fica aí
assistindo esse otário
e aí nós as crianças começa a dizer
professores a imaginar o san suu ky o
pata
aí eu caramba como é que pode ele
aparenta ter 13 14 anos ea galera já
dizer que não tem mais jeito então no
intervalo me aproximei dele cara você me
ajuda eu tô precisando de uma ajuda e
tal ajuda lá com a criançada eu percebi
que o guri lato de respeitar seu então
voltei pra saleiro não ligou não fico lá
e eu voltei para a sala quando estava
escrevendo a porta se abriu era ele e
ele sentou
aí eu fui de um apagador pra ele
a inapa gol aí eu me fez escrever
mostrou caderno expliquei inventei ou
beber água para deixar ele responsável
quando eu voltei ele estava sentindo
útil escrevendo a ponto dos alunos de
ver professor rené rapaz lá daí o
professor está falando e eu calma ele só
quer fazer uma pergunta
e aí chegou o dia de quem encerrará o
projeto no final de semana e os alunos
têm um cantar o rap de acordo com o tema
escolhido a escola lotada de moradores
professores os gerentes das empresas
e aí eu gente muito obrigado pela
conheceu o projeto e quem sai do meio da
multidão chorando a criança e ele veio
até mim e me abraçou cruzou dedinhos e
ficou chorando e me abraçando e eu
percebi que ele estava vendo embora a
pessoa que estava lhe dando amor carinho
e atenção
era isso que ele estava perdendo e às
vezes as pessoas correm atrás de bens
materiais sempre achando que falta
alguém esquece das pessoas ao redor
as pessoas às vezes precisam de uma
palavra mídia se aproxime nós nos
afastamos as pessoas às vezes só querem
se sentir amada às vezes estou em casa
está chovendo fico imaginando como tal
morador de rua e às vezes a gente tem
quatro cobertor cara pra que o egoísmo é
uma doença ea solidariedade é a cura
[Aplausos]